impos 20 % d'intention de vote pour
François Fillon derrière Alain Jupé
crédité de 36 % et Nicolas Sarkozi à 26
%. ce serait la hiérarchie du premier
tour selon le dernier sondage odxa en
attendant le dernier débat entre les h
candidats ce jeudi 17 novembre les
responsables ivelinois de la primaire
attendent une mobilisation importante
avec un impact des élections américaines
C fait aux États-Unis va permettre à
cette personne en disant ben oui les
sondage donne Alain Jupé 1er 2e Sarkozi
ben pourquoi pas aller voter pour
peut-être changer la donne on l'a
entendu encore ce weekend sur les les
marchés où les gens ont dit ben ça va
nous mobiliser peut-être encore plus
pour montrer
que la personne qui peut-être dans leur
cœur était en 3 ou 4e position ben
risque peut-être de passer en seconde
position il y a énormément d'attentees
au niveau du du peuple français et je
crois qu'on a véritablement une
alternance à leur apporter qu'on
pourrait être surpris par le taux de
participation dernière ligne droite pour
les préparatifs du premier tour avec 264
bureaux de vote dans les ivelines en
milieu rural on regroupe bien entendu
les villages pour dans un seul et même
bureau donc il peut y avoir 4 C villages
regroupés et il y a des affichetttes qui
seront installées àosées sur la porte
d'entrée de chacune de ces mairies dans
lesquelles il n'y a pas de bureau de
vote pour que les électeurs puissent le
le savoir facilement les résultats c'est
une originalité remonte directement à la
Haute Autorité c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y
aura pas de résultat le soir commune par
commune ou département par département
c'est la Haute autorité qui centralise
tous les résultats les bureaux de vote
seront ouverts dès 8h ce dimanche 20
novembre pour une fermeture prévue à
19h